[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the final
your fantasy fire drill of the preseason
all the preseason action that's behind
us now we are seven days away from the
kickoff between the cowboys and the
buccaneers i'm matt camp welcome in our
fourth and final show now if you drafted
already get your questions in we'll talk
about your teams maybe you drafted some
injured players we'll get to that coming
up in just a little bit but maybe with
the extra time between the end of the
preseason and the start of the regular
season
you have drafts coming up i can help you
there we'll talk about risers and
fallers my preseason takeaways injuries
and plenty of your questions get them in
in the brf i'll be answering them
throughout the entire show let's jump
into it injuries
we had some big ones at the end of the
preseason and more news coming down in
the last couple days we'll start with
your questions here jay lutz 44 i
drafted jk dobbins in the second round
what do i do please help first of all
jay lutz sorry and to anyone who's
already drafted before the injury
happened sorry
you know injuries are gonna happen yeah
hope when you come out of your drafts
you'll be fine okay stuff will happen in
the regular season but this happened in
the final preseason game so what now
what do you do if you invest in a top
three or four round pick in jk dominance
first of all don't panic don't go out
there and make a blockbuster trade okay
because if you do that you're probably
going to hurt yourself elsewhere points
don't matter where they come from if
you're loaded at wide receiver if you
have one of the best tight ends
sometimes that means you're hurting
elsewhere that might be happening right
now you might be looking at your running
back dev chart going oh boy what do i do
you move everybody up a spot because you
are going to hit the waiver wire we
talked about this last week throughout
the regular season you're going to win a
championship because you hit the waiver
wire many times at the running back
position throughout the regular season
that's just the nature of the position
now you don't want to go into the season
with someone like jk dobbins already
done but do not panic do not make some
kind of blockbuster trade i see this
happen way too often when you hurt
yourself elsewhere don't play on tilt
sit back
relax move everybody up your depth chart
and hit that waiver wire because there's
a good chance some big name will end up
being there after week number one
p mounts so i drafted irv smith jr
was this a mistake well hindsight yes of
course now it seems like a mistake
because this knee injury is terrible
news for irv smith and now i don't think
we're gonna see him at all
i also don't think you drafted irv smith
as a top eight or top nine you hoped
maybe he would finish inside the top ten
a tight end this year and i get that
he's a talented player but now you don't
have him
and unless you had one of the top five
or six tight ends i would say you were
probably going to end up with an irv
smith or you know a gerald everett or a
rob gronkowski or evan ingram or
somebody like that where you're going
i'll play them and we'll see what
happens and i think that's what's going
to happen with the tight end position
you'll be looking at match-ups you'll be
streaming maybe you have two you know
lower-end guys and you're just
alternating them or playing the match-up
i think that's what this is so it stinks
that you don't have irv smith but i
don't think it's a death blow to your
team hit the waiver wire look around
maybe play the match-up game i'm okay
with streaming tight ends and hopefully
you stick on one of them uh cainer says
what round would you consider drafting
michael thomas knowing he has that foot
injury well here's some actual news on
michael thomas that's somewhat concrete
more than we heard anything else he's on
the pup list that's six weeks you forget
about michael thomas now where would you
take it with that news
second to last round something like that
if you have an ir spot maybe you know
around earlier than that you throw them
on there but i do want to say this as
great as michael thomas has been it's
been one of the best in the business
reality fantasy it doesn't matter we
don't know
what shape game shape physical shape
whatever you want to say michael thomas
is going to be in when he is able to
come back who says he'll be back for
week seven that's not a guarantee maybe
even if he is back for week seven what
level is he going to be at so don't look
at the name value of michael thomas and
go well i'll have a wider senior as soon
as he comes back i would love that to
happen i'm not banking on that happening
so good questions there's relates to the
injuries uh one more i want to talk
about though quickly i mentioned earlier
evan ingram
calf injury and this just kind of plays
into the giants as a whole you know he
might not be out there for week one
kenny gallaudet has been banged up with
that hamstring it certainly seems like
we're going to see saquon barkley but
evan ingram's numbers to me when they've
been good have always come because of
opportunity and volume and i say that
because he's been kind of the last man
standing at times and there's been other
injuries there the team's not very good
and well we got to go to ingram because
who else we're going to go to that's not
going to be the case this year now i
don't know how good the giants are going
to be
if things go well they could be a 10 11
win team they could win the nfc east you
could have some good fantasy production
there that's what we're all hoping for
but to me when you have gallaudet and
barkley and sterling shepherd and darius
slayton evan ingram's just kind of a guy
and he is someone i've been looking for
reasons not to draft this calf injury
probably makes it that much easier let's
get to some more your questions as we
talk about the risers and fallers coming
off of the offseason coming off of the
preseason and all the injury news let's
start with justin here took a chance on
gerald everett because he has a better
qb and doesn't have huge competition at
seattle what do you think well by
competition if you mean at the position
of tight end sure i don't think you know
you're worried about the other tight
ends in seattle but the competition in
terms of targets and touches but that
would give me concern tyler lockett tk
metcalf chris carson just to name a few
all better players all more important
players for the seattle offense gerald
effort for me i have him around 13. a
low end tight end one a backup you know
someone that if you pick up you throw
them in there and you hope for the best
and if it doesn't work out you probably
cut them loose and move on to somebody
else is it a better quarterback
situation than playing with jared goff
of course it is but i don't know if the
situation as a whole is exactly
optimistic for gerald everett being a
great tight end he's just kind of there
he's not really a riser or a fuller to
me because i didn't have him that high
to begin with moving on here to jade
dawgs jade dawg says it's crazy to pull
the trigger on najee in the first round
pick 7 14 team so as we talk risers and
fallers here i say he's a riser but i
don't think he's a riser all the way to
pick seven end of the first round
probably somewhere in the the first half
of the second round for me najee harris
based on when he has played and the
other running backs there in pittsburgh
everything has looked good you don't
have to worry about a rookie running
back you don't have to go well he hasn't
played before in the nfl i can't trust
him there have been plenty of good
rookie running backs that have come
through at a high level including
players that you're gonna play from week
one and players are gonna go in the top
five zeke did it alvin kamara did it you
know chris mccaffrey did it niger harris
going to be just fine so seven's too
early but i do feel better he's risen up
my board just a bit
uh d card what's max draft value after
being declared
qb one
not someone i'm making an effort to go
get i will say that mac jones i am happy
as a whole for the patriots and the
fantasy value of all the patriot skill
players that mack jones is the
quarterback and not cam newton but to me
mac jones is not even a top 20 fantasy
quarterback now maybe down the road as
we learn more about this offense and i
think it's an offense that's going to be
somewhat in flux you know it wasn't
great last year now we're going on to a
rookie quarterback and mack jones we'll
learn more maybe late in the season he
starts to get it going the matchups look
pretty good you pick him up you know i
don't i think maybe you throw him as a
qb too and you're deep for two
quarterback leagues but i think the
numbers for mack jones won't be anything
special for fantasy but he'll be a help
to the other patriots around him so good
news as a whole
but for mac jones specifically doesn't
matter much for fantasy purposes let's
talk about my risers and followers now i
want to go with a name i just mentioned
i mentioned him a couple times alvin
kamara's actually moved up and that
probably sounds a little ridiculous but
i will say this
now we're talking about adam chapman
being hurt michael thomas at least six
weeks out of the mix there
who were they going to in this offense
they're going to alvin kamara i would
argue that alvin kamara
could actually be the number one overall
pick in fantasy football because talent
and opportunity if you get both of those
things you have a top top top tier
player that's what alvin kamara is chris
mccaffrey going number one as the
consensus but for the same reasons that
chris mccaffrey is going number one are
the same reasons you can make for alvin
kamara both players on decent for
probably average teams at best where
they're clearly the focal point of the
offense and even more so in the case of
alvin kamara who have moved up a couple
spots now in my top three running backs
uh also we just talked about mack jones
damien harris has moved up my board uh i
actually think he could find his way
into the top 12 at running back now the
bellatrix i've talked about them for
years and years and years different
running backs getting used but i think
this is the guy starting michelle
getting traded to the rams is helpful i
i just like where mac jones is going you
see the adp there 68.3 i think he will
outperform that adp obviously he's going
off of somewhat you know not knowing
about the quarterback you know sony
michelle still being there so i think
you'll see drafts as you still do them
over the next week he'll go a little bit
higher but he's certainly moved up to me
i think he's gonna wind up as a nice
volume rb2 one more name and this is
more of me just thinking about it more
is matthew stafford he has become my
quarterback target draft because you
don't have to take him early you see
where the adp is at 85. that has moved
up a little bit he's a riser on his own
but as i think about it more
he is the target to me at the
quarterback decision i'm not trying to
get the homes with josh allen or lamar
jackson because they're gonna have to
take them too high jared goff averaged
nearly 4 300 yards a season while with
the rams
there's going to be more reliance on the
passing game
with stafford at quarterback especially
with cam akers going acres
being in there yes i know they traded
with sony michelle yes i know they have
daryl henderson but i think staff
becomes that much more important
stafford is a far more talented
quarterback than jared goff and jared
goff put up good numbers with the rams
will be more touchdown opportunities i
am really really feeling matthew
stafford and i think he legitimately has
a chance to finish as a top five
quarterback the only thing that hurts
him is the lack of legs how about
players that are falling for me based on
where i had them to start the preseason
and now and i'm going to throw kenny
galladay here hamstring injury as i
thought has lingered i think he'll be
out there for week number one we'll see
the lack of any buzz for the giants as
well not a lot of you know exciting news
on a team that i think hopes they'll be
exciting but a lot of things have to
fall right uh to me now kenny gallaudet
it's pushed him firmly into the wide
receiver three conversation this is a
guy who we considered a low end wide
receiver one at times with the detroit
lions a two invest a two at worst i
should say but now with this injury i i
just
i wanna feel better about the giants and
i don't so kenny gallaudet with the nc
on top of everything else really right
now not even inside my top 25. he has
fallen a little bit at the wide receiver
position let's talk about miles gaskin
for the miami dolphins everyone expected
him to clearly beat the guy and i don't
think that's going to be the case at
least not what we saw in the last month
that could change but i was hoping to go
into the regular season with miles
gaskin right on top of the depth chart
with no concerns whatsoever in the miami
backfield and i can't feel that way it
looks like a running back by a committee
we're gonna see malcolm brown we're
gonna see salvin on med you know i
thought it was his job to lose i don't
want to say he's lost it but he doesn't
have that firm grasp on it and i'm not
exactly excited about the dolphins
anyway so he's dropped a little bit i
thought he'd be a very solid rb2 and i
would kind of look at him as a flex play
to start the season with the hope maybe
his play will move him up in the world
one more here let's talk about deandre
swift they brought him up last week this
team stinks the lions are not good he
has the groin issue they've talked about
maybe you know his wind his conditioning
not being great he's a far from proven
player the numbers were fine last year i
talked about jamal williams last week
all of these things concern me so
could he be a top 15 running back i was
hoping so initially that's why i had him
ranked i have dropped him down i would
hope
that he'll end up turning into a very
solid top 20 running back this year but
i just don't feel good about the
situation you know when your head coach
who wants to run the football and
talking about your conditioning maybe
that's just smoke and mirrors coach
speak you know it could be a bunch of
lies they don't have to say a word to us
what i will say about swift and
gallaudet any of these injuries we
brought up with these followers the
first official injury report does not
come out until next week it'll come out
early in the week for the buccaneers and
the cowboys and then on wednesday for
the rest of the game so that's when
we'll get some more concrete injury news
unless it's a michael thomas will they
end up on the pup and they have to
declare that before the start of the
season you're not going to get official
injury reports until next week so swift
is a name gallaudet is a name to keep an
eye on as we talk about the preseason
what about the takeaways before i get to
mind let's get to some of your questions
uh cairns cans 1128 which winner of a
preseason quarterback battle will have
the most positive impact on the fantasy
outlook of his teammates i think mack
jones is in that conversation
i think ryan fitzpatrick clearly being
the guy i feel better about jameis
winston and i'm not saying he's going to
be anything great but taysom hill is a
gadget guy taysom hill is not a starting
nfl quarterback to me you could do a lot
with taysom hill but i'd rather it be
jameis winston not saying james winston
will be great but at least i know what
he can do out there and he is a typical
quarterback in that way so it's better
news there he probably highest up on my
list but of all those names i mentioned
nobody you're super excited about for
fantasy purposes more so in reality
let's move on here a good question from
cairns abby wants to know whose
preseason success will translate to
the regular season
is that a najee harris i think that's
fair look the preseason you look out a
lot differently right now because it's
only three games teams are smart enough
to not put guys out there because they
don't need to so you know i look at
rookies getting chances i look like mac
jones getting the chances and i think oh
there could be something there
um it's nothing that i really get
excited about though sometimes it's it's
not getting injured and just going okay
this team looks good like there's not a
lot of news about the rams offense other
than what happened with the running
backs you go
all right that means nobody got hurt
that means we're feeling good you know
the fact that we didn't see saquon
barkley they're playing it smart
probably gonna be fine good to go week
number one so it's more about avoiding
those injuries nothing bad happening
that's what i want out of the preseason
i say this all the time if there's
off-season news and it's real news 95 of
the time
it's bad news if you avoided bad news
i'm feeling good about you as long as
nothing really went wrong and rankings
can stay as they are for a mccaffrey or
a camaro or a dak prescott or guys like
that you're going okay as long as things
are looking good that's what i'm taking
going into the start of the regular
season another one here from chris
johnson whose stock rises the most
because of other players a pre-season
injury look we've talked about daryl
henderson with cam acres being down
although tony michelle hurt that a
little bit um gus edwards is obviously
the hottest name right now with jk
dobbins out for the year and i did
mention this with dobbins i thought gus
edwards would stay involved the ravens
used gus edwards they used dobbins they
use lamar jackson which you cannot
forget all of these guys were gonna
touch the ball in the backfield but gus
edwards
because the ravens are a run first team
that's not going to change even though
they've made improvements to their
passing game and made some additions the
bottom line is this is a run first team
gus edwards is at the front of the line
of a run first team the team trusts him
he has proven he has taken the big leap
i think he can finish inside the top 15
this regular season at the running back
position now some of my takeaways let's
get to these i think and i know that
carson wentz and the o-line looks better
and they're off the coven list
i am not in on the colts
i'm kind of looking for reasons to not
trap jonathan taylor and i know you're
gonna look at me and go wait a minute
he's he's ranked inside your top 14 at
running back and he's going at the end
of the first round he's going at the top
and second round these are all true
things and in the right spot i would
probably still take him but there's too
much to prove here for the colts with
the o-line issues ty hilton now out of
the mix do you feel great about those
receivers like paris campbell or michael
pittman who have you know dealt with
their own issues in recent years
there's not a lot here that i'm excited
about and i feel like this is a team
that's going to take some time to gel
and figure it all out now that might
mean that it's a lot of jonathan taylor
and i hope that's the case but if i'm
kind of looking for tie breakers
you know if it's an aaron jones or a
jonathan taylor when in doubt i'm going
with the better team if it's a jonathan
taylor or one of these wide receivers
that's pushing down the board whether it
be tyree kill or stefan digg with
deandre hopkins i might just say you go
you know what i'm gonna play it safe and
i'm gonna take someone like one of those
wide receivers versus jonathan taylor i
just wish i could feel better about the
colts and i don't the broncos
the broncos could be sneaky good for
fantasy teddy bridgewater gets the
starting job i would also throw that
name previous question i kind of saved
it for here into something that's better
for all the fantasy players around him
you feel good about jerry judy portland
sutton looked like he was good to go at
the end of the preseason
the backfield could it be a little
annoying we'll see i like no offense
i've always liked noah fan there's a lot
of good things here now teddy
bridgewater i think is hyped up
sometimes a little bit too much there's
people that liked him coming out of
college that really never gave up on him
and even though he's never really been
that good it's all right he can do it i
think he's a better player
ceiling wise than a drew lock which is
better for everyone around him i kind of
like denver i think there's some
intrigue there and when you look at the
division and the defenses that they will
face with the chiefs and the raiders um
you know i don't get too scared off
about it obviously the charter's better
defense there as well but i kind of like
the broncos for fantasy and you don't
really have to make any massive
investments in terms of where their adp
is right now and once again and this
goes back and this is an unfortunate
bummer but it's realistic
we're back to like a handful of good
tight ends you got kittle and kelsey and
darren waller and mark andrews and
hawkinson and even a rookie and kyle
pitches in that conversation but after
that there's a lot of questions whether
it be noah fan you know we've talked
about evan ingram we've talked about
everett we you know rob gronkowski where
does he fit dallas got it pretty solid
you would have liked to have seen earth
get traded away but that didn't happen
so we're back to if you get one of those
five or six tight ends that everybody's
excited about you should have a big
advantage but if you don't it's okay
because you're probably gonna play the
streaming game but if you get one of
those top five or six you do have a big
advantage unfortunately we're back to
only a handful of truly elite tight ends
all right you guys may have drafted
already and if that's the case you've
got some teams that you need me to look
at so let's take a look at what teams
look like after drafts are done here
because you have sent me your rosters
let's take a look at texas nation what
do you think of my team aaron rodgers
antonio gibson josh jacobs pretty good
start there davonte adams oh i love the
double rainbow there rogers adams justin
jefferson pits claypool in the flex uh
kicker and defense i don't care neither
should you bench is looking good with
jujo melvin gordon fine as a bench
player landry uh what else we got there
malcolm brown beasley carr look i will
say this i don't think you need first of
all texas nation
good job on your team uh this is a very
strong team and you're not really
worried about too much here you're great
at every position clay plus the flex is
good to go i will say i don't think you
need to keep a derek carr around you got
aaron rodgers if aaron rodgers gets hurt
or when it says bye week go pick up
another quarter back then go grab
somebody else grab a lottery ticket kind
of player that you can stash away
marquez calloway for the saints if he's
out there maybe stash taymor somebody
like that deck station you got a great
team there uh but a guy like carr kind
of useless on the on this roster because
you have a number one quarterback
already and aaron rodgers so good their
job there by texas let's see another
team here um
hey oh so first pick in the ten man so
let's see where did you go with that you
went with uh
well what running back to take i think
he took chris mccaffrey on this team i
saw this team earlier but i look at this
team here aaron rodgers again uh miles
sanders who's not getting a lot of love
he's a fine rb2 dk mech aflam great job
at your first two receiver spots kittle
obviously solid montgomery edmonds this
is a good team once again a good team
here a 10 team or i will tell you this
if you go into the regular season in a
10-teamer and you have a bad team you
did something wrong in a 10-team or
unless it's two quarterbacks or a
massive starting lineup you should
pretty much have a good team so this is
a good team on paper i think the depth i
mean geez cooper cup on your bench is
great he's probably in there over you um
but this is a good team it's a solid
team there picking out of the number one
spot i'd be happy with this once again
you feel good about it but always be
thinking about that waiver wire you're a
little light at running back not awful
uh i would just be keeping an eye out on
the wide receiver excuse me the running
back spot one more here from zorro ten
teamer had picked seven tyler murray
davonte adams allen robinson
uh deontay johnson very good one two
three there jonathan taylor but james
robinson mike kasich there's a spot i
don't feel great about because he's a
right on the cusp of the tight end one
conversation but i look in your other
here you got mike davis you got sermon
uh you got michael thomas you got corey
davis carter i think that's david
johnson there so you got good depth i
would look around i would look around
the tight end i'm not saying make a
trade but also you don't have to stick
with gosicki but the rest of this team
is so good that here you go great
example you are so loaded at wide
receiver you have the number one wide
receiver to me and devonte adams alan
robinson is in the middle range of that
wide receiver one conversation uh
deontay johnson a solid two obviously a
lot of mouths to feed in pittsburgh but
you're so loaded there you got a low end
rb1 and jonathan taylor you got a
high-end rb2 and james robinson you got
some depth there i would look around at
tight end
i would just say hey i'm interested in
tight end what does somebody have to
give me but i'm not running to go make a
trade there all right so good jobs all
these teams 10 team are like i said they
should look good but don't forget you're
going to go hit that waiver wire at some
point anyway it's just the nature of
fantasy nowadays all right some burning
questions here as we finish up our final
show seven days before the start of the
regular season ram says who do i draft
with the fifth pick and a 10-team full
ppr so let's think about what a draft
could look like
probably mccaffery goes probably dalvin
cook goes uh alvin kamara i feel like
that's what we're kind of settling into
maybe zeke's gone there maybe derek
henry's gone there
if those names are gone i am very much
happy
very happy to take devonte adamson five
no problem whatsoever very safe in a
great offense aaron rodgers back if you
get jaunt adams at five you're good to
go don't feel like you have to take a
running back in those first five picks
full ppr you know a little hit to derek
henry a little bit is he the best
running back
in reality in the nfl he very well could
be but always remember not gonna have a
big role in the passing game and julio
jones there as well rams i'd love to
take devonte adams at five if alvin
camaro were to fall there or henry
you're good going there as well uh let's
get another one here from tim
tim has a question about the chiefs we
have patrick mahomes
or draft travis kelsey i will take
travis kelsey not 10 times
not 50 times but 100 times out of 100
i'm taking travis kelsey you never have
to take quarterback early i'm just i'm
telling you you don't have to do it
travis kelsey's going to be a first
round pick maybe top of the second round
pick he is going to give you such an
advantage tight end position and you can
go get somebody later on go get aaron
rodgers you can go get matthew stafford
go get tom brady i know mahomes is great
i get it but you don't have to take a
quarterback early give me travis kelsey
give me the number one tight end in all
of fantasy football and let me build a
round in early in my draft you use an
early pick on a quarterback you're
probably going to hurt your team it's
gone this way forever you watch any of
the industry drafts or expert trash or
anything like that you're not going to
see quarterbacks go early that's not a
mistake you can find that position you
can fill in that position or you can
draft it a little bit later on a couple
more questions here one more question i
have to say as we'll wrap things up here
and this one comes in from freddie trade
travis kelsey paris campbell but gus
edwards mike williams and robert tommy
no no no no no you are trading away the
best player i know robert tanyan
probably in that top 10 conversation but
paris campbell
uh you know is he on top of the depth
chart right now for the cults he very
well could be just just think about
targets you know i know i know mike
pitman's there as well
but i'm trading away the best player in
this deal gus edwards is solid we know
his stock is on the rise but as a whole
as we look at the other side of this
deal
it doesn't give me much excitement mike
williams is fine robert tonya is fine
gus edwards is more than fine but you're
trading away a star caliber player oh a
league winning player
a stud
one of the best if not the best at the
position and you're getting
pieces back
that doesn't get me if i'm trading away
travis kelsey i want to be fired up
about my return i am not fired up about
gus edwards mike williams and robert
tonyan not worth making the deal i don't
know why you're doing this deal i'm
guessing you're probably hurting at
running back maybe you lost to jk
dobbins but i think you're hurting your
team doesn't matter where the points
come from because if you have a guy like
kelsey guess what you have the advantage
of tight end every single week not worth
making a deal like this i want to thank
everybody for joining me here for the
last four shows a little extra time
before now between now and the start of
the regular season so don't tinker
things too much obviously keep an eye
maybe there's some more cuts to be made
maybe there's a trade to be made in the
nfl not your league but take your time
take a look at those injury reports next
week you're gonna find out some
information we didn't necessarily know
uh i want to thank you once again hit me
up on twitter with your questions at the
mat camp there good luck to you in the
2021 fantasy football season go win some
championships i'm matt camp and this has
been your fantasy fire joke
[Applause]
you